[Music]
Oh, I wish
so much that I could fly back to the city I used to live
in.
My name is Mohamed Ahmed Shamaa, a refugee from the
north. He is 12 years old. I was displaced from the Litwan roundabout from the
north. We went to schools on the beach.
All I found was the tank arriving at the
school gate and the body parts thrown away.  At the door, we slept
one day in a school called the Gaza School and College. We
found it there. We sat there the day we tied
our things and went to the south. The first time we came to the area, we sat in a
tent and gathered to get to them
from the street, from the mountains that had fallen, and we
bought barbecue sticks. We bought reels of two
lines. The first time I flew in the area, it happened.
Everyone comes to fly and settle with him. She flew. I was happy when she came when he
flew. Not when I do it. Why not? It's
high. We play on it and the
phones have to be charged. My cell phone and my father's cell phone came to me. They started telling me to sell, sell, I started to sell. Before that, they became jealous of me and bought
Audi.  What is Palestine? After I
flew, I mean, it's the first time I'm talking to them. Bring your
own bags. I'll make them the Tabqa Bridge, the Adan Bridge, and the Khattar. They came back a long time ago, with
colors and colors, and everything is still available to us
after the war. I wish I had a house like the one I
used to live in.  I played in it and found that
our house was gone. The apartment that followed us was gone. I hope
that the war will end and we will return to our turn.
God willing, we will find our house
standing.